this looks like pad thai hmm hmm it
looks like Thai food you would think
maybe it would be typing but it's not
it's different
incredible I don't know what this is
some kind of meat what is this in fish
cake this game of course fish cake
what is fish cake oh this is delicious
what it what is this whoa this is great
hold on so that is like drinking maple
syrup but you could only have a sip oh I
like will give me a tummyache
but then I'd be like worth it but I want
to know why there's like green strings
in it I don't like the way they're
shaped like a grow your own Loch Ness
monster kind of sailing around so what
is this it cube little slice of heaven
yeah this is perfect this is exactly
what you would want and she's fun
I could eat up very sweet much sweeter
than like American soups it's very fishy
a Singaporean chicken soup maybe a pod
national dish well this is elaborate I
like how everything's separated like one
of those like design your own cookie
sets why are they separated it's so good
does it like a metaphor some what are
you trying to tell me okay well this is
sticky rice that's the blandest chicken
I've ever had I guess that's why you
need all of these sauces just dip it in
whatever you want oh my god it's not
spot okay there it is mm-hmm it's a
little spicy please turn the cameras off
because I'm going to eat this whole
thing it's gonna be sad Singapore does
it pretty right
delicious Singapore Thai food is like
thanks on you right now and they're not
better
Singapore food is better so I don't know
what Thailand is doing to get a bunch of
people to be like Thai foods my first
state option for my OKCupid date but
Singapore you could take them you just
need to like try and believe in yourself